everyone was going on welcome to another
tkinter tutorial video in this video
we're gonna be talking about is how we
can add a graph to our two kitchen
window so we want to graph the actual
like Bitcoin price at the time and then
so for now we need to figure out a way
to stuff a mat plot live graph into a
teak interior window so for a lot of
people this has been a long time request
because people want to either add
buttons to mat pot live or take away
buttons and add just add their own kind
of flavor to their matplotlib graphs so
congratulations here is your long waited
video so so this is our baseline
application and then we're basically
just going to we've since we've got this
application to add more pages all we're
going to do is we're going to add at
page three and page three is going to be
a page that contains a graph so to begin
matplotlib is not built in to Python so
if you do not have matplotlib installed
or you have an old version of matplotlib
installed i highly suggest you update
your version if you want to use
matplotlib styles unless of course you
followed my older version of the
matplotlib styles where we just kind of
worked around it because for a while
matplotlib styles was an ability but it
wasn't built into matplotlib but with
the newest version 1.4 of matplotlib you
have matplotlib styles so if you don't
have a map out lib where you need to
update matplotlib you can come to
matplotlib org and then go to downloads
and then here all your downloads if
you're on a 32-bit windows here's your
download if you're on a 64-bit windows
here's your download download that
install that also obviously make sure
you match your version of python so so
that's at that's matplotlib download
that install it make sure you can go to
an idle window so idle like this I'm not
sure which one is 2 or 3 but I'll just
pick one
where is it there we go okay make sure
you can do import matplotlib and then
also if you want to make sure if you
want to find out if you are on the
current version or the the most recent
version that we're going to use I want
to say it's from Matt plot live in poor
style yes okay make sure you can do
those two things that's what we're going
to need in this video if you can do
those two things you'll get through the
rest of this series with matplotlib so
close out of that and move matplotlib
out of here so now in our application
what do we need to do so we're gonna
come to the top of our application bump
some stuff down and we're going to go
ahead we have extra kind of a lot of
things to import here we're going to
need at least import matplotlib we're
also going to use a TK AG so that's
matplotlib use and then in here you put
t k a GG mind the caps that's a capital
T capital a lowercase K and lowercase G
G what's this this is the back end
basically a piper of math loud loop so
depending on what your uses are and if
you want to shove matplotlib and this or
that you can change up the back end also
well really that's that's the menu so
when you're using matplotlib in various
scenarios you might want to change the
back end so that everything jives so mad
hot lib dot use cool now what we want to
do is um hold up let me think here see
what we're gonna do um let's go ahead
and i'm going to try and avoid using
numpy in my example i was going to have
a caesar numpy but i don't i don't wanna
have to make everybody get none pi just
yet but what we're going to need to do
is we're going to go ahead and import
our so go from matplotlib dot back-end
dot back-end underscore TK AGG import so
from this nastiness import what and
we're going to import figure
um it's probably running in my pretty
face here in a minute so let me just
bump this down so import figure a canvas
TK AGG uh and then the navigation
navigation tool bar - TK a GG okay
mind the caps here so this is our canvas
and it just sounds just like it is it's
what's going to allow us to draw a map
plot live graph to a canvas 40k Hg and
then also this is the navigation toolbar
if you're not familiar with matplotlib
that's like the bar that allows you to
go forward back home save zoom all that
stuff so we want that obviously hmm so
we get that um and also I will just say
I did say obviously but there may be a
scenario where you don't want that and
you can actually get rid of that or and
you can even make your own buttons to
make them look better we're going to go
ahead and use it but if you wanted to
get rid of it you actually you can
actually get rid of it um so anyway uh
the next thing is we're going to go
ahead and go from matplotlib import
actually format lib figure import
capital F figure okay so that's all of
the imports that we're going to need so
I'm going to bring this up now and once
you have that we're ready to make our
page three so to do that we'll go ahead
we'll roll we will retain one of the
buttons but we'll go ahead and not have
all the buttons so let's just go ahead
and copy and paste page two like all
this copy and then we'll just come down
here over and paste and now we got a
page - we'll rename this to page three
and we'll call this will change this TK
dot label to say a graph page and then
if you recall to add a new page we
basically just take the name of this
class we'll come up to the very very top
and
and add that to our little tuple here
boom now I've got page three and we can
navigate ourselves to page three and
then we also need a link to it so let's
go ahead and add a link to it in our
start page class so let's just copy and
paste here whoops
cop there we go pastes Oh call it button
three button three instead of that page
two page three and then we'll call this
graph page cool so now we save and run
this hopefully everything works cool so
here is our thing we'll go to graph page
and boom it says like graph page back to
home cool but now we need to actually
add a graph to it so how do we do that
so we'll come down here after we pack
the button now we want to add we need to
add the canvas then we need to like show
the canvas and then we can actually you
know put stuff to the canvas and we can
also add in our navigation bar if you
want it and then um and really that's it
because then we out basically will
actually go my bad well plot first so if
you're not familiar with matplotlib or
any form of graphics generally what you
do is on the back end you draw
everything on the back end and when
you're all done drawing things then you
like render it bring it to the front
okay so the when it comes like graphics
and stuff the calculation of graphics
usually is very fast is the displaying
of graphics that is very cumbersome to a
computer so so once we've once we've
done the packing and all that we need to
do our typical matplotlib code so first
we're going to say F for figure equals
capital F figure and then so we're gonna
define what this figure is so for now
we're just going to use the simple stuff
I was telling you that you can use grid
and all this but for now I'll just make
it a really simple figure and the figure
is going to be fig size equals and we'll
make it a 5/5 and then we'll add DPI
equals 100 so that there's our simple
figure if you want to know more about
like all the things about matplotlib I
have a massive map plot Lib tutorial
series and we're actually going to be
using a lot of the elements from that
map
tutorial series so if you're interested
in learning a lot more about matplotlib
or like what exactly we're doing or how
you can maybe customize this chart
however you want to have a graph
definitely check out that series if if
you have any questions or anything on
matplotlib chances I've got a video I
can at least link you to the proper
video so F equals figure now we want to
add a we'll go ahead and add a subplot
to this so we'll say a mr say a equals f
dot add underscore subplot and then here
we just give the the number so it's a
one by one and this is plot number one
that's what 1 1 1 means so if you did 1
by 2 that would be a 1 by 2 this is
chart number 1 and so on but 1 1 1 just
means there's only one chart um then
we'll go ahead and we'll just do a dot
plot and then we'll just plot um
just a simple graph so we'll just just
do 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so that's our our X
and then we'll do comma and then we'll
make a Y list we'll just do to do
something like that
let's make it something else let's make
sure it so that was one two three one
eight one two three four five six seven
eight wow I'm good okay so now we've
plotted the data and so in our like
matplotlib object here we've got this
lovely graph but it's in the background
so now I want to like pull it to the
foreground
normally in matplotlib you would
basically run a PLC show and boom
there's your graph it would pop up
lovely but that's not what we want we
want in our tkinter window so we're
basically going to have to do what plot
dot show typically does - a few things
so after we've plotted now what we want
to do is we're going to bring them bring
up the canvas basically so we're gonna
say canvas equals capital F figure
capital C canvas and then T k AGG mind
the caps um and then that's F and self
so F for the figure self for itself um
tell us canvas then we're going to do
canvas dot show and then finally um
we're going to do canvas dot get
underscore TK underscore widget empty
parms dot pack so we're basically like
packing in the canvas to tkinter like we
always have so keep in mind you could do
pack and you can also do got grid so dot
pack um and then we'll just say side
equals uh TK dot all caps top and then
we'll go ahead and do fill equals TK dot
both and then expand equals true so as
usual this kind of Orient's it to the
top fill means it will fill everything
to the space that you've provided it
with pack and then expand just means if
there's any more white space beyond what
you say or have allotted this widget
expand to that space easy peasy now um
in theory that would be basically uh
basically it I think but we're going to
want we want the navigation bar as well
so we're going to do um and actually
we'd have to do I think one more thing
and let's go ahead and see if that would
pop up but I don't I don't think so but
we'll see no there it is
okay so there's our graph it's actually
inner tkinter window so at this point we
don't have like that could be it right
there's no navigation though so we can't
really do anything with this chart
normally matplotlib also displays like
where your mouse is this F has a decent
hover ability and I like the navigation
bar you might not so you know if you
don't want a navigation bar for whatever
reason that's how you could do the graph
without a navigation bar now let's close
this for those who want a navigation bar
what do we do
so we'll come down here and we'll say
toolbar equals and then we're going to
say navigation toolbar whoops not a
capital B toolbar to T
ka GG mind the caps and then canvas self
now so that's adding the toolbar to the
canvas now what we do is tool bar dot
update and then finally canvas dot
underscore TK canvas dot pack and then
uh let's go ahead and we're just gonna
use the same rules for packing here copy
that paste and now let's go ahead and
run this graph page and there are our
our typical navigations now I at least
on on the chart that I've been doing so
like this is all the navitor yeah
basically navigation bar so as you can
see the hover stuff is down here at the
bottom a bottom right I kind of like it
when it's at the top but you might you
know you might have all your preferences
but obviously since this is a tkinter
window so we can actually put this
anywhere so we're using Packer right now
and giving it its own little widget
space but we can use the rules of
tkinter to move this anywhere you want
so on matplotlib you don't really have
the choice of where it goes what you do
actually put not easily not as easily as
this so uh let's close out of this so in
theory what could we do well we could
basically take this cut and then we can
just throw it basically right up here
actually shoot we won't get away with
canvas here hold on hold oh okay so what
we can do then actually is pro is just
like this so cut that part and paste
that down here let's see if we get away
with that No
why am i failing that is the question
mm-hmm I thought I would get away with
that but let's do we can do this instead
so like let's go like that side TK uh
bottom let's try something like that
you're killing me you're killing me what
am I missing
what if what if what if
take this you son of a [ __ ] okay oh I
can't win I can't win today guys that's
okay
that's interesting let's go to the sauce
this one's on the bottom as well right
so anyways that's how we can add a graph
now the next thing that we want to do is
we want to learn how we can make this
graph live so the idea is to pull data
either from the exchanges or from cVTC
and actually make the data update live
without having to like refresh the page
so we can make it pretty easily just by
clicking refresh or something like that
but we want the page the whole page to
refresh and it turns out actually that
we can we can do some pretty neat things
actually when we bring in matplotlib and
use the animation function of map olive
I don't know how you would do something
similar in tkinter because if you knew
how to do something very similar in
tkinter you know maybe you could have
like a back-end daemon running and then
you could have that daemon actually like
update the ticket or window but I've
actually found that it's really easy
just use matplotlib xanimation function
and while you're at it why not make the
animation function actually be your
back-end daemon so anyway you'll see
what I mean in the coming video but yeah
next video will actually make this graph
live animal also will use map Holub
styles and make this graph look pretty
quickly so if you guys have any
questions or comments regarding this
tutorial video please feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching things for all the spoil of
subscriptions and until next time